[Musique]
monsieur pour l'élection
la vente est aujourd'hui là
d'énergie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur jean luc mélenchon pour
les élections présidentielles les
entremetteuses deuxième chose c'est plus
facile de militer ici parce que bas les
gens qui sont ici sont issus de
quartiers populaires en majorité et nos
thématiques l'été magic touch plus
facilement la personne qui en précarité
et que les difficultés voit qu'on a un
bon accueil les gens ils sont contents
de nous voir ils se contentent prendre
nos tracts pourquoi il très l'impulsion
de discuter avec nous donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est agréable
de venir militer devant ce quartier
[Musique]
on est sur un chantier parce que la
condition des travailleurs
c'est un sujet que moi j'ai envie
d'aborder sur cette élection
présidentielle parce qu'on n'en parle
pas assez mais c'est ça la réalité de
nos concitoyens c'est celle sociale donc
il faut qu'on aborde ce thème là il faut
qu'on parle du pouvoir d'achat des gens
de leurs conditions de travail - sans
celui qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur et c'est de ça que j'aimerais
qu'on parle qu'on dit cette élection
présidentielle
alors à mon père il travaille dans le
bâtiment donc dans des chantiers comme
ça où dans un métier vraiment qui est
dur et en plus ils travaillaient tous
seuls il était un entrepreneur jeu en
fait du coup un jour mon papa est
diagnostiqué un cancer un cancer des
poumons
comme il était tout seul continuez à
l'hôpital bel échantillon sais pas au
bout d'un moment on nous met tous
tellement endettés et les chantiers
prenait tellement de retard ce qui était
obligée d'engager des gens pour
travailler à sa place parce que du coup
en fait c'est une traque était à perte
et c'est quand même incroyable de se
dire que quand tu es malade en plus de
sa maladie est à la source du stress de
comment je vais faire pour nous et mes
gosses comment je vais faire pour
pouvoir conclure payer mon loyer du coup
tu veux tu peux pas tu peux pas lutter
c'est pas possible de lutter contre eux
[Musique]
moi je me suis engagé au crime dans le
côlon parce que justement il a des
mesures qui peuvent aider ces gens là
déjà l'augmentation du smic à 1400 euros
net parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
vivre dignement avec un avec un smic
donc jean luc mélenchon c'est
l'augmentation du smic c'est la
réduction de travail et c'est la
retraite à 60 ans et ça devrait être
comme ça pour tous tous les gens
[Musique]
donc c'est l'humanité à chaque édition
il ya l'homme où la femme du jour une
fois j'ai eu l'homme du jour gaspard
fontaine un décrocheur au coeur bien
accroché il n'a que 19 ans mais la force
son engagement on peut déjà un militant
aguerri fait insoumis et qu'il y en en
droit comparé et c'est ce 23 mars devant
le tribunal d'amiens pour répondre du
vol du portrait du maquereau le
procureur a requis 500 euros d'amendé
contre lui le verdict sera rendu le 20
avril cependant gaspard quand elle n'est
pas un voleur le simard 2020 qui a
décroché la photo dans la salle du
conseil municipal damien ville dont le
président est originaire
la bataille qui a engagé les décrocheurs
est une bataille sociale parce que la
bataille écologique a une racine
exclusivement sociales gloire à gaspard
et aux camarades dillon l'action
mon vieux port
jean luc mélenchon qui vient de se tenir
c'est la plus belle chose qui pouvait
m'arriver allez arrête c'est quoi la
plus belle chose qui pouvait nous
arriver à ça c'est mon fond d'écran donc
c'est moi et que j'aurais fait l'enfant
parce que quand je suis sortie du
tribunal
j'ai vu jean luc mélenchon qui a était
venu me faire un câlin pour me féliciter
d'avoir fait mon action est de me dire
que j'avais raison que tu es bien du
coup c'était un grand moment pour moi je
et c'est en fond d'écran puisque c'est
un moment historique de ma vie
[Musique]
la justice de mon pays reconnaît que moi
j'ai raison j'ai raison de dénoncer ce
qui se passe j'ai raison de dire que
emmanuel macron icher pas nécessaire
pour pallier le dérèglement climatique
j'ai pas le nécessaire pour endiguer la
précarité y
il mène pas des politiques qui sont à la
hauteur des enjeux actuels
simplement
vous appelle rudi votre fils en garde à
vue quel que soit l'âge eu forcément se
contentent m un peu gros sur la patate
quoi c'est pas que non plus au plus tard
on m'a dégagé beast quasi physicien
pardon par rapport à ses bottes de cow
ce moment j'en ai plus on peut citer de
noms mais honnêtement je suis rassuré
moi je ne fais pas de politique dont je
ne
je ne ferai pas ce genre de choses pour
si on voit que ce soit ça m'a surpris
semble surprendre parce que c'est vrai
que quelques casses personnellement
c'est quelqu'un qui est ceinte d'un des
valeurs simples tepa qui l'accompagné ne
vivent dans le terme en argent
bénéfices c'est vrai t'as jamais été
demandeur de quoi que ce soit non plus
tu aimes les choses semblent de la vie
et je pense que ça te ressemble c'est
vrai cela ne vous ressemble complètement
va démarrer par un petit porte à porte
qui sur ces barres d'immeubles où l'idée
c'est de présenter donc
ceux qui traquent avec l'essentiel du
programme qui est à l'arrière ça me
prend beaucoup de temps en fait vrai
mais faire un fois je choisi de soutenir
la création devant luc mélenchon et j'ai
envie qu'il gagne et pour le faire
gagner il communique t il faut
convaincre les langues donc je fais il
vous dit plus probable devrait en faire
l'annoncé là je trouve qu'elle est smic
ni 400 honnête je pense que c'est
faisable on se rend compte que les gens
s'intéressent beaucoup plus qu'avant à
la faute politique parce que mon gilet
jaune ya tout et là y'a pas un final qui
est un truc qui mobilise beaucoup les
gens ils s'intéressent en fait à ce qui
se passe actuellement il s'intéresse au
débat public est en fait ils n'aiment
pas ce que mc qu'on y fait d'autres sont
contents qu'on leur propose des
alternatives et convient on le vend
maintenant on peut faire autrement et on
va faire autrement
l'action militante elle repose aussi
beaucoup sur ces
qui s'engage c'est essentiel pour la
même manière que les générations qui
nous ont précédés nous ont vus nous même
évolué non les a vu arriver comme
gaspard le dit quoi d'abord par
curiosité que aujourd'hui être des
piliers de l'organisation militante donc
c'est un passage de témoin en quelque
sorte
[Musique]